es gab früher ein meme Format namens
Troll science und deswegen ungefähr so
schritt eins einander halten Schritt 2
Person A hebt Person B hoch Schritt 3
Person B Personal auch hoch und Schritt
vier beide fliegen boah
die meisten sind ziemlich unlustig aber
eins fand ich absolut geil und zwar das
hier ein Auto mit so einem Magnet vorne
dran das von einem anderen Magneten
gezogen wird und da der Magnet auch am
Auto befestigt ist fährt er immer mit
und permanent magnet Beschleunigung
jetzt wäre es natürlich geil wenn das in
echt auch mit so einem Magneten
funktioniert würde und einige von euch
die mir das Video hier auf Instagram
vorgeschlagen haben glauben dass
scheinbar auch aber tut natürlich nicht
umso mehr werden sich die Leute wundern
wenn ich das Teil jetzt mit ein bisschen
schummeln einfach trotzdem bauen und sie
dann eigentlich diesen Magneten vorne
ins Auto dran stecken können und dass
ich dann wie durch Geisterhand bewegt
ähnlich wie der eine PC nicht mal gebaut
habe wo man einfach Magneten dran halten
kann und der sich dann unendlich dreht
obwohl es eigentlich natürlich nicht
funktioniert
dieses Video wird unterstützt von MSI
mehr dazu später als erstes brauchen wir
dafür ein Auto und das konstruiere ich
jetzt hier in CAD ich will es möglich
simpel halten aber jetzt nicht ganz so
langweilig wie in Demmin man soll ja
schon noch erkennen dass es ein Auto ist
ja das mit den beiden Magneten wie
natürlich nicht wirklich funktioniert
was wir später übrigens auch noch eins
zu eins zu nachbauen werden um zu zeigen
brauchen wir im Inneren zwei Motoren
damit für den Außenstehenden genauso aus
wie das wird's funktionieren bevor ich
jetzt aber ein ganzes Auto um diese
Motoren herum Designer schaue ich
erstmal anhand eines Prototyps ob zwei
davon überhaupt genug Power haben um das
ganze Auto zu schieben dafür suche ich
mir erstmal einen richtig schönen
holzklotze aus ja genau der muss es sein
Job dann zwei Kugellager als
provisorische Vorderräder dran zaubern
hübsches Holz Grad an der
Standbohrmaschine
[Musik]
verlötet dann den Motor mit zwei Kabeln
in kleiner Griff in die Schublade der
Schande herauskommt ein Kabelbinder mit
dem ich die beiden Motoren kurzerhand
einfach ins Auto Binde und dann die
Räder dran steckt die mittlerweile sogar
eine Gummierung haben und nach etwas
höchst professionellen Kabelmanagement
zack fährt das Auto und um diese beiden
Motoren drumherum konstruiere ich jetzt
in das Auto ähm den Motor habe ich jetzt
hier schon mal auch in CAD quasi
reingezogen manchmal unsichtbar und dann
die macht man das mit dem Auto blödsten
ich glaube das war von der Seite es soll
ungefähr so sein dass der Formfaktor mit
dem Magnet irgendwie zusammen passt mal
ganz grob haben wir hier 17 für Magneten
85 das Auto 85 durch 17 das heißt Fünfer
so groß wie der Mann jetzt soll das Auto
sein also machen das Auto 20 lang
[Musik]
gut das ist jetzt die Form fürs Auto
finde ich sehr nice jetzt freue ich noch
irgendwie eine Einlassung wo die Motoren
reinkommen stimmt aber nur hinten
eigentlich ja die Maße 15,1 mm mal 20,1
da ist ein bisschen Luft dann mache ich
aus der 2d-fläche mal was drei
dimensionales richtig nice jetzt muss
ich den Motorrad irgendwie rein kriegen
das sieht schon mal gut aus aber
eigentlich sollten ja die Rede auch
eingelassen sein ne dann bastel ich mal
eben ein Rad
[Musik]
die will ich später übrigens aus dem
Holz hier machen das ist 9,5 mm dick
genauso das Rad
jawohl doch das was ich jetzt mache ist
eine Fachsprache der Radkasten
[Musik]
entsprechend weiter rein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dann weiß noch ein bisschen schräger
soll ja kein kompletter Cloud sein an
so ja so ist es eigentlich ganz geil und
ich würde sagen so machen
ich hatte jetzt die Idee einfach mal
bevor ich es baue das meme
auszuprobieren mit zwei Magneten ich
habe hier den Prototypen von vorhin und
den ersten Planeten bin ich jetzt auch
noch mal eiskalt im Kabelbinder drum rum
[Musik]
so 100% TÜV zertifiziert und wenn ich
jetzt den zweiten Monaten dranhalte und
immer genau auf dem richtigen Abstand
bleibt das Auto ziehen
ja ich glaube das Prinzip so dann
brauche ich meistens nach zack
so jetzt habe ich noch mal fest nicht
dass das jetzt gleich komplett ist ähm
ja und wenn ich jetzt los lass mich
sehen wenn sie nichts und diese jetzt
eben das Auto tatsächlich einfach
losfährt sobald man hier so Magneten
kann fast vergessen davor braucht unser
hübsches Auto natürlich auch noch ein
Haltevorrichtung für die Magneten
idealerweise ein bisschen schöner als
die hier und damit man den vorderen Zug
Magneten wie ich ihn jetzt einmal meine
nicht so umständlich dran friemeln muss
ist die Stange einfach drehbar damit man
den Magneten easy hindrehen kann jetzt
der sich noch die Frage welche Farbe das
Auto haben soll das habe ich das ganze
in Blender einmal fotorealistisch durch
rendere damit ich das Auto nicht
lackiert und hinterher erst rausfindet
dass die Farbe gar nicht passt schwarz
nee blau
nee auch nicht gelb ja das Knall nice
für die Konstruktion Berechnungen aber
auch Renderings verwende ich übrigens
das MSI self seventeen Studio NSA
heutigen Videos ist einer der weltweit
führenden Entwickler und Hersteller von
computer hardware egal ob Gaming oder in
professionellen Umfeld das def7 Studio
ist mit Abstand das heftigste Notebook
das ich jemals gesehen habe und ist
obwohl es so schlank und edel aussieht
performanter als alle Desktop Rechner
die wir haben dank der NVIDIA GeForce
ATX 4080 Laptop GPU im Intel Core i9
13900h 64 Gigabyte DDR5 RAM und zwei
Terabyte SSD mit dem 17,3 Zoll großen
Ultra HD Bildschirm und 144 Herz freue
ich mich auf viel Platz maximale
Auflösung und flüssige
Bildwiederholungsrate beim Gaming und
kreativen Arbeiten auch dank Nvidia ATX
Studio Support was heißt das ist
speziell optimierte Treiber für 3D
Animation und Videoschnitt gibt und mit
einem 99,9 Wattstunden großen Akku mit
extra langer Laufzeit der aber trotzdem
noch im Flugzeug mitgenommen werden darf
ist das ein wirklich absolut
kompromisslose mobile werkstation mit
WiFi 6a thunderbol 4 und USB 4.0
Anschlüssen seid ihr dazu kommt sicher
aufgestellt also klickt auf den Link in
der Videobeschreibung für mehr Infos zum
Studio so jetzt lass uns einfach mal
diese Karre bauen ich habe hier so ein
richtig geilen Holzblock aus dem dieses
Ding gleich geschnitzt wird vom Computer
aber diese Bodenplatte die ich gerade
noch rein konzentriert habe und zwar aus
diesem dünnen Holz dass ich hier schon
drauf geschraubt hat und zwar von der
letzten zweitkanal Video diesen Katapult
hier so drauf da
klicke
[Musik]
dann geht ihr los
ging jetzt vergleichsweise flott damit
das Holz da während des Fräsen sich
rausfällt ist es dann noch mit so halte
Stegen befestigt die der Fräser da eben
halt einfach noch stehen gelassen hat
[Musik]
so richtig
erste Teil fertig
ja ich habe dafür einmal zwei mal so ein
richtiges vorbereitet einer davon ist
schon eingespannt und im ersten Schritt
wäre jetzt mal richtig gut Plan gemacht
let's go
[Musik]
boah
nicht so schnell
[Musik]
und unter
die beiden Teile sind epic
atemberaubendaten okay so übertrieben
aber ich finde es geil und man kann es
nicht jetzt gleich zusammenpacken es
sieht aus wie ein richtig nasses Auto
finde ich ich muss jetzt später noch
absägen dann ist das erstmal fertig
allerdings behalte ich diese Reste weil
ich da noch mal was rein Fräsen muss und
zwar im Leben für die ganze Elektronik
und da seht ihr gerade jetzt wie die CNC
das auch noch auf der Rückseite ein ist
[Musik]
während der Leim getrocknet ist sind
dann auch noch alle anderen Teile fertig
geworden und nachdem der lang getrunken
ist wird alles einmal geschliffen
die Magneten hier zu befestigen ist ein
bisschen eine Challenge dafür biege ich
eben so ein Draht hier zu Recht den
verträgt dann und den verzögerten Gras
den schraube ich jetzt quasi einmal
dieses Holz rein und dieses Holz stecken
dran da kommt das da rein
und jetzt kann ich das Teil hier einmal
genauso wie es mir vorgestellt hatte
einfach hin und her schwenken eben vor
die andere Magneten und es ist auch mal
auf der gleichen Höhe das war ein
bisschen in der Challenge noch die
Motoren an den Boden und ihr werdet mal
verschraubt
[Musik]
das sieht jetzt ultra geil aus wir sind
jetzt genauso weit wie bei diesem
Prototypen den habe ich übrigens auch
schon auf Instagram gepostet der kam
richtig gut an und ungefähr ein Drittel
der Leute die mir geschrieben haben
dachten das Teil wird echt funktionieren
ich weiß nicht was das über meine
Community aussagt aber wenn ihr in
Zukunft auch schon während des ziehen
ziehen wollte bevor Youtube wieder
online kommt dann folgt mir auf
Instagram aber jetzt sorgen wir endlich
dafür dass das Auto plötzlich zum Fahren
anfängt wenn man dran ist dafür braucht
man Magnetsensor und den haben wir zum
Beispiel schon in diesem Video benutzt
mit dem Unendlichen Computer Lüfter der
von dem Magneten angetrieben wird und
wenn ich mir jetzt jemand geklaut und
hier da dran geht dann verändert sich
der Wert je nachdem wie stark dass man
nicht gefällt ist und je nachdem ob es
jetzt plus oder minus geht nach unten
ist eine ziemlich coole Sache damit kann
man exakt messen wie nah der Magnet
eigentlich dran ist ich habe den Arduino
jetzt mal so programmiert dass wenn ich
hier ein Magneten dranhalte je näher
dran geht desto heller leuchtet eine LED
und danach habe ich den gleichen Test
gemacht nur das dann eben der Motor
angetrieben wird er fragt euch warum der
Mann ist in so einem komischen Zylinder
drin ist naja das Problem ist immer hier
das war super hübsch aber mega Spaß also
wenn ich die jetzt gegen den Effekt sein
sollte ist der Ausschlag echt super
gering und bei diesen anderen kleinen
hier ist ja schon direkt viel viel höher
und hier vorne verstecken weil dann
sieht man den davon außen deshalb habe
ich hier hier drin auch so ein Loch
geboren genau hier und da lege ich jetzt
Magnet rein und jetzt gebe ich einfach
den Sensor ins Innenleben genau
gegenüber von diesem Magneten hier ja
ungefähr hier rein
jetzt beweg ich den Magneten eben direkt
vor den anderen Magneten der andere Mann
ist wieder erkannt und der Mutter bewegt
sich wie durch Magie und das sieht jetzt
aus ist jetzt irgendwas mit diesem Mann
zu tun hat er natürlich gar nicht damit
ist hier der Kunde jetzt fast fertig
ein bisschen kompakter steckt ins Auto
rein und danach glaube ich kann das
Testen jetzt wird also die Elektronik
verlötet und verlegt und am Ende auch
noch mal verklebt und wenn dann der
Boden unten dran kommt ist die auch noch
gut versteckt aber bevor wir jetzt
unsere erste Testfahrt mit dem Magnet
machen fehlt erst noch der Lack und
dafür wird das Auto noch mal komplett
zerlegt
[Musik]
das magnetauto und wenn ich jetzt diesen
Hebel hier rüberbewegt
ja dann soll es eigentlich angehen
ach deswegen ging das nicht die Motoren
Arbeiten gegeneinander okay die Motoren
gehen jetzt bei den gleichen Richtung
vorgeschoben
und er fährt geil noch mal
[Musik]
geil mach die Magneten hierhin und das
Auto fährt er weg Alter ist das nice
dass das funktioniert das ist das
magische nicht ganz so magische
magnetbetriebene nicht ganz normal
betriebene Auto ich werde das jetzt mal
auf tiktok posten und nicht auflösen was
genau ist wenn ihr wissen wollt ob die
Leute in den Kommentaren da drauf
reinfallen das ist echt funktioniert
schaut mal bei mir auf tiktok vorbei und
schaut auf jeden Fall auch bei MSI
vorbei über den Link in der Beschreibung
da gibt's richtig heftige Laptops ich
bin damit drauf macht's gut